Of course, you donated a million times.
What? So, you're picking on random stuff
that have no relevance. I got to go.
Bye, Piers. God bless you and what
you're doing. Oh, I'm sure you have to
go. I'm sure you have to go. Your
paymasters, your paymasters are watching
this. You have to go.
This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
On the day of judgement, the first thing
we will be asked about is our prayer.
Now, imagine being part of a project
that teaches thousands of people around
the world for just 100 pounds. You can
help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. And
when they teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. [music] Do not
miss the Sadaqah Jariyah. Donate today
and earn rewards that [music] last
beyond your lifetime. Go to the link and
donate now.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are ready,
inshallah. So, this is a video of
Lowkey, alhamdulillah, um dealing with a
insecure
uh subhanallah, a woman with inferiority
complex who defines the who says that
she's a Muslim who's trying to suck up
to the white man, you know, accept me,
accept me. Look, I dressed like you, I
look like you. I've dressed, you know, I
dressed half naked, etc. to prove myself
to you cuz I want to, not that I am
oppressed by the sexual objectification
of women and the beauty industry and
opposite gender and whatever to the No,
no, no, no, no, I I choose to. I choose
to Accept me, accept me, accept me. I'm
against agreement gangs. Interesting.
Here is how it went and how she ended up
walking off when facts were thrown out.
So, she's from the UK Reform Party.
response Okay.
>> Lowkey. The point here is that Reform UK
is funded by Christopher Harborne, who
is a resident of Thailand and has an
alternative name that he uses. Reform UK
is also funded by Jeremy Hoskin, who is
a resident of Ireland. Both of them have
business interests all over tax havens,
why are they unpatriotic? That is
insulting to the people of this country.
The second point, to address what was
mentioned before, there's a book by the
name of the Islamophobia industry social
movements from above. There's a chapter
in it by Sarah Marusek. She analyzed the
Islamophobia industry, which includes a
plethora of things like
the
>> Oh, oh, she got triggered. Oh, she got
triggered. Reform Party, the two
individuals that he
he mentioned who are avoiding tax. Yes,
the rich is getting richer, the poor is
getting poorer. Why are they making you
guys fight Muslims? Those days are over.
People's eyes open. But look how she
gets triggered when he mentioned those
facts and 70% of those who fund the
Islamophobia industry are what? Wait
till the end. Look how she gets
triggered. Watch this. I am not
interrupting you. So, I haven't I didn't
interrupt you. So, what? So, what? I am
Muslim. I am Muslim. So, what? What does
that prove? I am Muslim. I am Muslim.
What is that? An argument? I haven't
finished making my point. Please allow
me to finish. Everyone else did.
Everyone else did.
Please allow me to finish.
75%
of Ah, okay. So, she already knows a
book and she's like, I don't want to
read it cuz she knows what's coming. So,
she already knows about the book. How do
you know about the book? Why are you
triggered? Why are you raising your
voice? Why are you cutting low-key?
organizations that fund the Islamophobia
industry also fund the building of
illegal Israeli settlements in violation
of the four Geneva Conventions. Ah,
somebody's paymasters. Somebody's
paymasters got exposed. 78% or whatever
the numbers he mentioned that fund
Islamophobia are the very ones that are
still funding the settlements in
occupied lands in Palestine. She got
triggered. I wonder why. She's a Muslim.
Don't forget she's a Muslim. That is a
material historical fact.
>> about? We have We have
thousands of British white girls who
were tortured and raped by Pakistanis.
Hold on a second. Hold on a a What
What's has got to do with anything?
I don't understand. It's so bizarre.
What's this got to do with anything? You
want to What What Muslims came out and
condemned and it's got nothing to do
with Islam. Zero. Bring your evidence
that the action that those culprits done
has got nothing to do with Islam. Zero.
Not only that, in Islam they'd be
hanged.
You would love the Sharia then, wouldn't
you? You would like to adopt the Sharia,
you know, Sharia coming and taking over.
We can fix your problem of these
criminals. We'll deal with them once and
for all. No taxpayers' money, no hot
food, hot shower, hot bed, hot food. No,
no, no, no, no. We'll deal with them
once and for all. No, no, no.
Well, let's kind of let's What has this
got to do with anything?
>> The majority of child sexual
exploitation in this country are male.
Are male.
>> Hello, excuse me. Are you stupid? You
just interrupted him.
Well, I said I play the victim like
she's acting like a paymaster. Okay. Oh,
are you interrupting me? You interrupted
him first. The majority of those
carrying out sexual crimes in this
country
in this country Okay, let let Layla
finish her point.
That is a complete myth
by you and others like you.
Let let Layla finish her point, please.
Look, I am a Muslim, right? Why is she
keep repeating that? I am a Muslim. It's
like again, I am a Muslim. Look at this.
I am a Muslim. Okay. And I do not
appreciate we have a Labour government
that's trying to push Islamophobia laws,
trying to criticize and criminalize any
criticism of Islam. That is not what
Britain's about. Britain is about
freedom of speech and the freedom to
criticize everything. We have Pakistani
Muslim rape gangs that Really?
Everything? Can you deny the Holocaust?
Yes, can you go to the Jewish areas and
tell them to condemn Epstein Islands and
the Gaza genocide? Can you go and do
that? Can you criticize? Can you say
Jewish
pedophile gangs in Epstein Islands? Jews
Can the Jews condemn that? Can you?
You'll get arrested, wouldn't you?
ignored to protect a Muslim block vote.
We do have Islamic radical terrorism in
this country. It's not No other kind of
terrorism. And I have to speak out
because I recognize that there are
millions of Muslims like me who don't
feel that way. We don't associate
themselves. But to pretend that it is
not happening in this country
is actually a danger to this country. We
have
>> What's she on about?
Look, listen. [laughter] This this this
this terminology and words, these are
old. Those days are over. People have
woken up. Do you think grooming gangs
and this and terrorism those days are
over.
Layla, whatever your name is, those days
are over. Just stop trying to cover the
Epstein files. Okay? Don't start with
the try to cover it. And there's a Jew
there, a Zionist Jew. Yes? Look what he
has to say when Jinx exposes him. Well,
let's carry on. Look at this one walks
out and I watch.
>> Chris Hunter who were convicted to Chris
Hunter
>> convicted who were convicted Can you
just be quiet for a second for Christ's
We have a convicted terror uh bomb maker
from the Muslim Brotherhood from Egypt
who arrived illegally on a boat and that
was granted asylum, put in a hotel in
London at the time That's interesting.
And the word Brotherhood, Muslim
Brotherhood has been used a lot.
By pro
uh these Zionists. If you know that
terminology, Muslim Brotherhood, Muslim
Brotherhood, it's being used a lot. And
you can see now they're all using the
same terminologies. Those who are
sucking up to the Zionists and Zionists
themselves, Muslim Brotherhood, that's
keep popping up here and there. spares
expense. There is something
fundamentally wrong with the way we
discuss radical Islam in this country.
And I agree, it's not taking over the
country. Of course not, but it does
represent a national threat. And uh
Muslims in general the majority of them
come here to integrate and assimilate
and they're all like me. But there are
some that come to Britain and expect the
country to change for them. And if it
doesn't change for them, we get people
like those on your panel calling it
racist. There's nothing racist about
that. It's called patriotism.
>> Okay. No problem. Let's let's carry on.
This is where she walks off. I'm not
going to sit here I'm not going to sit
here and argue with this guy who has no
idea what he's talking about. I'm
Muslim. I know millions of Muslims like
me and we do not like uh radical Muslims
coming in here and giving
>> don't like radical Muslims
Nick Candy is in the Epstein files. Did
he know Ghislaine Maxwell? What's your
Ooh, Nick Candy. Who is Nick Candy?
Let's see. This is where she gets
triggered. And and can you imagine
grooming gangs? Imagine somebody that
was there that the leader of the
grooming gangs, Muslim grooming gangs,
and somebody met them
from the Labour Party. Oh my gosh. But
it's fine. Who's Who's Nick Candy? And
and has he done any wrongdoing? And
What's your response? And has he done
any wrongdoing by being there? You can't
ask this. The question is open.
>> him for a business deal. The Right.
Well, we're not I wonder what business
deal that could be. It's a business
deal, guys. I wonder what business deal
that could be. Bloody Peter Island.
We're talking about number We're not
talking about Nick Candy. We're talking
about immigration. How is that
>> Ooh, HE'S THE TREASURER OF YOUR PARTY.
Somebody destroyed that party, didn't
he?
Let's go. Look, he's a party people,
isn't he? Of course. He's donated a
million dollars to your party. So,
you're picking on random stuff that have
no relevance. I got to go. Bye, Piers.
Sorry. I've got to have a right of
reply.
>> doing. Oh, I'm sure you have to go. I'm
sure you have to go. Your paymasters
Your paymasters are watching this. You
have to go. You have to go. Now, look
how Jenk puts this Zionist
dirtbag in his place. Watch this now.
Oh, no, he can't be doing it. Force the
debate. No, you have to run away. This
is not This is not fair. To be fair,
hang on. Hang on, Jenk. Can I solve it?
To be fair Can I solve it? You guys You
It has been It's It's unbelievable the
answers you guys have been giving cuz
it's it's just been all deflection every
single time. But what about Epstein?
What about Nick Candy? You guys
I can say Listen, but Jenk Jenk, I'm I'm
a Jew, right? And I've already sat here
and I can say there are huge problems
that I find in the Hasidic Jewish
community.
Oh, really? Oh, really? Do you condemn
Epstein Island? Do you condemn Epstein
as a Jew? He was sitting down. There was
a Talmud behind him. Okay? And there is
a lot of things about non-goyims while
you guys believe about that you
can rape a girl and get away with
it. And you believe the is you
know
lower than you or God knows what else,
okay, that you guys believe about the
Yes, maybe there's a correlation
there. Huh? Maybe.
>> Why can't you guys when we talk about
the grooming gangs, when we talk about
Islamism, not just in the UK, the way
it's spread across the Middle East and
Europe, the things that are going on in
Iran right now. And I haven't seen one
tiny morsel of you know what, there are
some bad issues here. Every single
moment it's been deflection, so no
wonder Leila's gone. She can't be
bothered talking to people with an IQ
She's talking about my brother, we've
condemned all of these attacks, the
Muslim attacks, so-called
Islamic attacks, whatever it is by the
name of Islam, we've done it. You, my
friend, majority of Zionist Jews, they
don't condemn what Israel's doing. They
actually are for it. seven
You have the IQ of this desk.
>> Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, I know, I know. You
guys are super smart.
>> about something other than Epstein then,
cuz you're being asked about grooming
gangs. Hold on, hold on. Let me Let me
solve it. Let me you Let me address it.
Let me address it. Okay, can you address
it, Jenk? Before you do, let me just ask
you, can you address it
>> Can you shut up and let me address it?
Can you address it without mentioning
Israel? Or or can you address grooming
gangs?
>> No, because
>> Okay, no, can you Can you Can you
address it without talking about the
biggest pedo island where girls,
American girls and girls all around the
Western world were used by the top
echelon, the billionaires,
presidentials, candidates for that
matter, raping them, eating, doing God
knows what, satanic stuff. Can you talk
about something else? Let's talk about
grooming gangs of certain individuals
who have got nothing to do with Islam,
but let's avoid the big elephant in the
room and stop talking about Epstein.
Stop talking about Epstein, Jenk. What
happens? That's the whole reason we're
having this conversation cuz your
Israeli buddies wanted a distraction
from the Epstein files. That's why they
threw this garbage into the media. So
Can you just Thank you. Exactly. And
people are not buying it. They're not
buying it. They can see right through
you guys lying to us.
This not working. They try to bring the
grooming and Listen, my friend.
Please, move on. Move on. What happened?
We as Muslims, we know how we deal with
those culprits. Yes? That are criminals
who were arrested, move on. Okay? Gone.
They're They're scum of the earth. Let's
deal with the big pedo island. That is
but a
atrocity, my friend. And it don't work.
>> Piers just explained to you Yeah, that's
who I wanted to talk to. Piers Morgan.
>> up and let me address it? He's going to
go in for 30 years. You're asking me a
question and I'll answer it. You're
asking me a question and I'll answer it.
This is super easy. Why don't you arrest
everyone who's committed a crime? So, if
Pakistani grooming gangs exist, and I'm
sure they do, then arrest them. Where's
the question?
>> exist to arrest them, did they? Because
of people like YOU. SHUT UP AND let me
finish. If there's people Shut up and
let me finish. So, uh if there's a white
gang of people who are raping people,
arrest them. If there's a bunch of
super-powerful people who are raping
American girls, arrest them. This is all
super simple. But, when we go to arrest
anyone Thank you. Arrest them. Simple
solution. Arrest the criminals. They are
criminals. Criminals are criminals.
There's no white, black, green about
this. They are criminals. Arrest them.
Why are you making it an Islam Muslim
issue? Yes? Why are you making it a
Muslim and Islam issue? A demand to
arrest anyone in the Epstein files, they
go, "OH, THE MUSLIMS. THEY'RE RAPING
JUST THE MUSLIMS. IT'S ALL THE MUSLIMS.
EVERYBODY hate the Muslims." Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's an obvious diversion. That's
why we're bringing up Israel in the
Epstein files, cuz in the midst of the
biggest story that there has been in
maybe in my lifetime, all of a sudden,
the grooming gangs pop back up. You want
me to condemn them? SUPER EASY. I
CONDEMN THEM. I CONDEMN THEM 200%. Thank
you. Exactly. Done. Khalas. Beautifully
put. Fantastic. I hope they're in
prison. I hope they never get out of
prison. But that's not the issue. You're
not bringing it up because you're
concerned about victims. You're bringing
it up so you can say the dirty Muslims
did it. Now, let me explain something to
you, okay? If we had the same exact
conversation but you took out the word
Muslim and you put in the word Jewish or
Jew and we had a whole debate about
should we ban the Jews? Are the Jews a
problem in the UK? Do the Jews have the
wrong kind of culture? We would all be
canceled. We'd all have our careers
ruined. You would none of us would ever
work in media again. But here we are
having a conversation of is the problem
the Muslims and should we ban the
Muslims? Thank you. Exactly. Exactly.
Imagine we come and say Jews have a
problem. The Jews problem, etc. Boy,
man, I'll be canceled like this. Woof.
Happy days. And the Muslims have the
wrong culture. AND THE MINUTE YOU ASK
HOW DO THIS IS WHAT YOU DO and you're
doing fine. These guys have literally
bought our government. They have they
contributed contributed a bribe 94% of
Congress and you're telling me that the
pro-Israel forces don't have any power.
The real problem is Muslims who have
like almost no money or no power in the
UK, New York, or in America. So, this is
a joke. This whole conversation is
propaganda by Israel to distract you
from the Epstein files. Okay. Okay.
>> No one believes it anymore. My friend,
look at the guilt in your face, bro.
You guys listen, you guys have you
Zionists have your hands everywhere.
Everywhere. You guys have the biggest
sleeper cells around the world.
The whole world's woken up to your
reality. Look at his face how
uncomfortable he is.
You're exposed. And you don't like it.
You know it's the beginning of the end
of Israel. You know it. Okay. Andrew, I
want to hear Andrew's I want to hear
Andrew's response to that, please.
Andrew. Well, it's just absolutely nuts.
You've been going on for half an hour
there just about oh, you can't say
anything about the Jews or whatever. If
there were 5 million Jews in the UK. now
there's actually about 200,000. If there
were 5 or 6 million Jews in the UK, if
there was a kind of a grooming gang
thing involved with this the Jews, I
would be the first person and most Jews
would be as well. The idea that also
that this this idea of Muslim all the
poor Muslims, this this reverse racism
that you're doing the whole time, right?
There are 2 billion Muslims worldwide.
They are in some of the richest
countries in the world and they are some
of the most powerful
>> again, if you're going to use that
logic, I can come and say you guys are
the lowest in population Zionist Jews.
You guys You guys are the lowest in
population Zionists and you guys done
the most heinous acts when it comes to
Epstein Islands, when it comes to Gaza
genocide, when it comes to owning
Pornhub and all these kind of places
that destroy people's souls.
You guys are behind it. You own
Hollywood. You Zionist. You have all
those subliminal messages in Disney, uh
perverted sexual stuff. You guys own all
of this adult industry. You guys are
behind all of this filth and dirt that's
destroying people's lives.
And you There is not even much of you
guys.
I can make the same argument against
Zionists. I have many more things to
say.
>> Andrew, you've defended Israel
relentlessly over the genocide in Gaza.
That has consisted of sexual crime at
insane levels. They're raping
>> No, that's not true, though. That's not
true. In Israeli military camps.
>> You haven't So, that's not true. Okay,
so you don't actually do what you say
you do, which is you call out everyone
>> Look, you're you're but you're a
conspiracy theorist. But you're a
conspiracy theorist. So, I don't know
what to do with all of these
conspiracies. Everything [laughter]
All of your arguments
>> You're a conspiracy
>> are this person's linked to that person
and I'm going to say something to
>> aside from your feelings, what have you
cited?
>> That's not true. You see, when it comes
to Gaza genocide, a genocide in 4K.
That's not true. Something that everyone
can see. That's not true. That their
leaders have quoted biblical scriptures.
The the the
uh
the Torah.
That's not true.
They say it their self. They record it
their self. He goes, "That's not true.
You scum. You Do you think you care
about white girls? You don't. You care
about yourself. You care about your own
ones and your own people. That's what
you care about. You don't care about the
British girls." Subhanallah. Brother
says, "That's all I have to say
inshallah." This fake ass liberal um
uh
Muslim, whatever she wants to call
herself, sellout walking out when she
was exposed. Subhanallah. And it All
these ties go back to
Israel, Mossad, Zionism. May Allah
expose them more. And they will cause
fitna in the land twice. And Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says, "Allah will send
service that are going to deal with them
inshallah." May Allah expose them for
what they really are. Till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. May Allah bless Lowkey for
sticking on him and Jean Wigger.
Goodbye. This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah
in town. On the day of judgement, the
first thing we will be asked about is
our prayer. Now, imagine being part of a
project that teaches thousands of people
around the world for just 100 pounds.
You can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me learn how to pray salah. And when
they teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Do not miss the
Sadaqah Jariyah. Donate today and earn
rewards [music]
that last beyond your lifetime. Go to
the link and donate now.